-This is so exciting.
"America's Got Talent:
Champions Edition."
-Yes.
-Very intense.
-It's the Olympics of talent
I mean, what people
don't know --
some people may know,
but there's 190 iterations
of "Got Talent"
all around the world.
There's like, South Africa
Germany, Norway,
and you know, you really
don't have bragging rights
until you win America.
America is the one.
We are the flagship.
So this is the Olympics
of talent. Seriously.
-And you see some
pretty intense stuff.
-Yeah.
-Do you ever see an act
where you come home
and then you just immediatel
have to tell your entire famil
about what you've seen?
-Oh, my God.
There was one --
this group, Duo Transcend.
And these guys were up
50 feet in the air
doing acrobatic moves
on a trampoline --
blindfolded, by the way.
-The blindfolded part
was insane.
-Blindfolded.
But you gotta understand this.
This was what was insane -
it was his wife.
Now, first of all, I drop
co-worker, I'd be like,
"Oh, man, my bad."
-Yeah.
-You know what I mean?
"Man, go get better.
I'll talk to you later," right
-Yeah.
-Your wife, dude.
If you drop your wife,
where do you go from there
-Yeah.
See, I was thinking about it
a different way, which is
I'd be up there, and I'd b
thinking back to the fight
we had two days ago.
[ Laughter ]
And she's be like,
"I got you, baby."
-I know!
-"You just put that blindfold on
and jump, I got you."
[ Laughter ]
-No!
-I don't know
if she's going to have me.
-Oh, no.
You're so right.
-Every now and then I'll hav
family members give me
feedback on this show.
Do you have -- do your wif
and kids give you feedback
on how you host
your show?
-All the time.
All the time.
They're like, "You're shouting
too much. You're shouting.
But I -- but I have to say this,
you know, my family --
we've been watching "AGT"
for a long, long time.
And they always like
everyone else.
You know what I mean?
Like, I'm like,
"I'm finally on 'AGT!'
It's me!"
They're like,
"Yeah, you're all right."
And I fight to get that kind o
validation from my family,
but this is the deal --
I'm very thankful because
they always keep it real,
you know what I mean?
You're in a world of sycophants.
-Oh, yes. As a family.
-You're in a world of people
who are like,
"You're the best, Terry.
You're so amazing."
And my wife is like,
"Look, man, sit down.
Your breath is really bad
right now."
And I'm like, "Oh, yeah.
Oh, I do need something."
You know?
So I learn to enjoy
the comments
and the criticism from
people who love you.
That's very, very important.
Only from people who love you.
-Yeah, and if they can
give it in a loving way,
that is all the better.
-It is good.
-Very exciting as well
that "Brooklyn Nine-Nine"
is coming back.
-Yes! Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It just, you know -- you know
it really is --
the thing that people
always say is going to happe
and so rarely does, this was
a show that went away.
Fox said, "We had a great run,
and thank you for everything,"
and then NBC picked it up
and now it's going to end up
at the very least, having
three seasons on NBC.
-And then Fox went away.
-Yeah, and then Fox --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-No, I got to tell you this.
You know what?
The big thing is that,
first of all, you know,
you have to understand,
when you create a characte
on a TV show,
it's a real person.
-Yeah.
-It literally is a real,
living person.
And when they cancel your show
it's like a death.
I mean, it literally flatlined
And we were all walking around
like, oh, my God.
Like, they killed
Terry Jeffords.
How could you do that?
You know what I mean?
-Yeah, yeah.
-That's literally what it was.
And we were saying our goodbyes.
There was a mourning period.
And then the Internet
and the people --
a hundred million comments
and texts and posts that wer
like, "What are you doing?
-Yeah.
-And they brought us
back to life.
And now, not only --
right before season seven,
we were already picked up
for season eight.
This feels like not only did you
come back to life,
but you've been given
the keys to the city.
You know what I'm saying?
-Sure.
-And it feels so great.
Our fandom is amazing.
-I can't wait to see
what you're doing in it.
That's just in a couple weeks.
And thank you so much
for being here.
-This is great. Thank you.
You are awesome.
-Always. Terry Crews.